بلوحات تشكيليه يلخص الفنان الفلسطيني
العالمي سليمان منصور الحكايه الفلسطينيه
مقدما الهويه الشعبيه لبلاده على شكل
لوحات تفيض بالابداع اعمال الفنان سليمان
منصور ومسيرته التي قاربت على الخمسين
عاما تعد احد ابرز تجارب الحركه التشكيليه
الفلسطينيه المعاصره حيث اثبت ان الفن
قادر على تقديم رساله واضحه مليئه
بالمعاني لوحات منصور العبقريه تاتي من
خياله الخاص المليء بالمشاهدات التي كونها
كونها خلال سنين عمره فهو القادر على
تقديم صور الحياه بلوحات تتالق بجمال وسحر
عفوي منصور ابن بيئته الفلسطينيه والمحب
لبلاده يقدم حتى اليوم لوحات تحكي تاريخها
وحاضره هذه البلاد واليوم يكون معنا
لنتعرف اكثر على هذه المسيره الفنيه
الناصعه التي استطاعت حجز مكانها
بالعالميه بعد سنوات من التالق
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو الفنانه التشكيلي
والنحات الفلسطيني العالمي سليمان منصور
اهلا بك استاذ سليمان معنا نورتنا شكرا
على تواجدك معنا في صباح العربيه شكرا لكم
شكرا للعربيه اهلا بك يعني توجز الحكايه
الفلسطينيه وتقدم الهويه الفلسطينيه على
الشكل لوحات غايه وتفيض بالابداع حدثنا
اكثر عن هذا الشعر
هو يعني في بدايه السبعينات وحتى لغيت
اليوم
انه اسرائيل
ناكره لوجود شعب فلسطيني والغرب اجمالا
يعني فاحنا كانه احنا مش موجودين
فكان موضوع الهويه وتاكيد الهويه
كان يعني الموضوع اساسي مش بس عندي الفنان
تشكيليين عند الادباء والشعراء وعند كل
اللي بيشتغلوا بالتعبير الفني
فاحنا كفنانين يعني اشتغلنا على
استخراج رموز يعني رموز بصريه عشان الهويه
موضوع تجريدي نوعا ما احنا كنا بدنا نطلع
رموز بصريه ممكن الناس يفهموها وبيتفاعلوا
معها فاخذنا من اربعه مصادر الاساسيه اللي
هي الفنون القديمه
الكنعاني
الفرعوني الاشوري الفن المنطقه يعني
اخدم الفن الاسلامي خاصه الخط العربي
والحرف العربي
بعدين اخذنا من التراث الفلسطيني ومن
المشهد اللي في الطبيعي من القريه
الفلسطينيه
بالاضافه
اللي استفدناها من
الفن العالمي اللي بيحكي عن موضوع الحريه
والهويه اكيد احنا كمان بنقول للمشاهدين
والذين يعيشون خارج فلسطين بان لوحه جمل
المحامل هي تقريبا موجوده في كل بيت
فلسطيني او لوحه العتال الفلسطيني الذي
يحمل على عاتقه ومسؤوليه فلسطين ككل اليوم
الى اي حد الفن من خلال النضال بالريشه
رسالته اقوى قد تكون ربما من لغه المعركه
وقيكون لك تاثير اكبر
لا لا انا بتصور الفن
يعني يعني معركته على عده طبقات اول اشي
يعني يعني احد المعارك اللي احنا بنوجهها
يعني انه في محاوله لانه
يقللوا من قيمه الانسان الفلسطيني
يعني انه هذا الانسان مش انسان كامل يعني
ما عنده ثقافه ما عنده حضاره
فاحنا من خلال الاعمال الفنيه مش بس بالفن
التشكيلي بالادب كله نحن بنحاول انه نقارن
هذه نعرك
طيب يعني لوحاتكم تتالق بالسحر وبالابداع
وبالجمال دليل على ذلك انها وصلت للعالميه
واستقطبت اعجاب العالم توقعتم ذلك ان تصل
الى العالميه وهذا الاعجاب الكبير بها
لا يعني انا بصراحه يعني ولا عمري حلمت
اني انا تكون في المعارض او متاحف كبيره
دوليه
يعني عشان هيك نجحت عشان انا ما لحقتش
الموضه
[موسيقى]
كنت دائما صادق في التعبير عن
يعني الوضع اللي بعيش فيه الشعب الفلسطيني
فالصدق هذا في التعبير
بقنع الشعب الفلسطيني اولا والشعب العربي
ثانيا وبالتالي لازم تقنع العالم بس اذا
انت ما قدرتي تقنعي شعبك بالبدايه ما
بتقنع حدا بالاخير فعلا طب استاذ سليمان
شو قصه النضال بالريشه والبطيخه في فلسطين
وكان اليهود يضلوا الجيش يعني كل ما يصير
يصادروا اعمال يعتبروها اعلام اعمال
تعرضيه
فمره انا عملت معرض سنه الثمانين فاجروا
سكروا المعرض بعد ست ساعات من افتتاح
المعرض سكروا الجاليري واخذوا المفاتيح
بعد حوالي ثلاث اشهر او شهرين
الفنانين المسؤولين عن القلبه اوكي
واعطونا اوامر كثيره اهمها انه احنا ممنوع
نرسم
الاخضر والاحمر والاسود والابيض اللي هي
الوان العلم تمام يعني احنا نرسم فيها
بتكون جنب بعض يعني اللي تبين
بس قبل هيك صاروا يناقشوا فينا ايش نوع
الفن اللي لازم احنا نشتغل فيه
فالضابط كان يناقشنا يقول ليش ما ترسموا
ورد انتم ورده ليش ما ترسموا مثلا امراه
جميله عاريه مثلا
حتى انا بشتري منكم
يبعدنا عن الفن السياسي عن الفن
بطيخه في زميل لنا
كتير غلبه يعني فبسال فهو سال الضابط
بس بالاخضر والابيض والاسود والاحمر
بنصدرها
حتى لو رسمته بطيخه سائحه بطيخه برضه من
صدرها يعني
وصاروا كمان الناس لما بدها تعبر ترسم
هالبطيخه بالوان الوان ابيض والاحمر
والاسود بحب اذكر انه في فنان يعني اللي
هو خالد حوراني كان اول واحد رسم البطيخه
بالمعنى هذا معنى العلامه
تحياتنا له نورتنا في السجن فنان تشكيلي
العالمي سليمان منصور شكرا جزيلا